hands going bros my name is Pippa I am
so late
I get it I am so late to play this
basically everyone's played it already
this is the finale of season 3 this is
where it ends what is gonna happen with
Clementine I hear it's a pretty good
ending I'm really excited to see how
this ends so here we go
thing is between us oh my god chance
they thought that shading was good David
is back in our lives now makes this
whole thing a little more complicated
but I can't I can't see her face I'm in
all the way with my god
really okay here we go
let's do this let's finish this together
that's right of course come on I wanted
to go back in the action I'm letting the
bone speak to me oh my god oh I think I
can hear them they're saying you're
gonna lose call my mierda so play
already
I must have inherited patience from MA
oh come on man
calm down David no one is ever in a rush
to lose so either two or one my beers
getting warm drink last night if he
plays his last boom oh great I would
have lost anyway kicked out of baseball
can't play dominoes what exactly are you
good at again hobby
who cares is you gonna kick Domino TVs
ball slugger that's enough both of you
it's not Patty's fault he's a disgrace
to the game of dominoes i won
that's ten bucks you owe me both of you
I know you're broke hobby you should sit
out the next game since we all know I'm
gonna win no shame and surrender we'd
all understand now don't break your hand
patting yourself on the back I'll beat
you next time should you even be betting
on these games
isn't that what got you in trouble to
begin with do we need to have an
intervention I'll keep on talking David
see what happens we got banned from
baseball because we were bad winning
means you get to be a little bit of
pendejo pendejo which of course means if
you can I'll copy in Oh was it your turn
to do that Transylvanian I lost track
poor helpless javi get my wallet needle
keep an eye on him you don't want him
snatching an extra twenty four gas money
it's on the cowboy he's so rude sure pop
all right huh what's this well you don't
go through someone else's wallet what
the [ __ ] I would never do that what I
honor the wallet code
what's huh what the [ __ ] is this none of
your business he has cancer how can you
read that from just a statement ah
really there was a lot of text down
there people get cancer you didn't need
to know that's not for you to decide
you look okay God you really should have
told us it's the right thing to do it's
my cancer I get to do whatever I want
you know now what difference does it
make how bad
it's okay mijo asked me how bad is it
you won't have to worry about paying me
back that ten bucks
Jesus uh-huh I said old David now you
haven't told my mom and neither will
either of you you hear me mouth shut
that's not okay pas you have to tell her
when the time is right I I will
that's not good enough it's good enough
for me you're gonna need her help with
this pot driving you to the doctor
getting prescriptions wait what are your
options
treatment stuff like that gained more
radiation all that expensive yeah
they're great when do you start I turned
it down turned it down you don't get to
turn it down so much money info like
another month another game of dominoes
to loose it's not worth it both still
playing ball Jesus Christ Lin paid for
it I'll pay for it it's not happening
save your money [ __ ] the money I can
afford it you can afford it David but my
pride can't let's play another game our
pride yeah crowd can you be a selfish
coward papi can you believe this [ __ ]
David I get it man it's not fair but
come on take it easy
sit down
both of you
you know I pray you see the one that
became in Somme in the beginning every
night your mother was pregnant with both
of you please God my daughter
anything but a son anything but another
me anything but another hot-headed idiot
with his heart in the right place
anything but another foolhardy handsome
gambler anything at all please papa
don't give up fight fight for our name
for our blood for our family please
fight uh it's your life huh ah [ __ ] I
don't know however you want dear as long
as you want
you're both the same only thinking about
yourselves David felt betrayed oh no yet
don't betray me next time David I don't
worry Pau he'll come around
you should have supported him wait what
I'm on your side still I'm gonna be a
name carved in stone before you know it
Xavier that'll be me letters on a rock
that nobody wants to visit I know you
think you're strong enough to handle
that alone and so does your brother and
you're both wrong you have to take care
of each other you two are all I'll leave
behind like Gabe and Mariana will be for
David legacy happier it's all anyone
leaves behind that and their bones be
brothers before it's too late
that's not too much to ask one last
favour for your old man
okay paw I'll try as hard as you can as
come on can we go back to the actions of
Jesus Christ I still need to pay they
with paw boy
if you had just won the game we wouldn't
have had this problem so you're blaming
me for all this I'm depending on you
mijo we both are
I wonder how if there's different
endings in this one like what the
outcomes are because there was a lot of
different endings in in the season to
which I really liked that was really
cruel all right here we go
finally Jesus Christ okay the zombies
are so slow like how could you possibly
die from them I don't get it
they always have like some [ __ ]
teleporting skill it's always like super
quiet and then yeah oh Jesus Christ
all right there we go shut the leg off
oldest trick in the book
everyone knows it takes three bullets to
shoot off a leg you're wasting a lot of
bullets there buddy Hey look teleporting
zombies everyone just shoot him in the
face thank you oh that was more than
bargained for I'm sick Jesus Christ oh
come on it just ate
hey treat oh she got ugly how she's lost
okay see you another teleporter
hey she's not here she must have gotten
out if something's happened to her if
you've gotten her
you better hope she's alive
how about it you're welcome I just saved
your life is that what you're thinking
about Kate's more important than your
ego okay okay [ __ ] this should go
seriously she was in the car she was
driving the day other [ __ ] Sammy
[Music]
thus it he finally dies I wonder what's
gonna happen I'm sure I found you that's
weird
ha ha ha hey Kate next time we yell out
[ __ ] Kate peace thanks for making it
back to me
Co she hugs though you're alive that's
right that's right I thought I lost you
back there
what the hell's the matter with you to
focus on your surroundings there's baby
look-ins oh come on please let's just
say game could finally die oh that was a
good set I got a great teacher oh my god
kill yourself sorry I'm sorry
I just hate him somebody slipped out I
hit him so much look at him there's so
many will be safer inside get in get a
great teacher geez I [ __ ] hate Gabe
so much stupid alright that was chapter
1 of episode episode 1 now we're inside
everyone that should what's gonna happen
you put up a good fight out there hey
Dad I'm glad you made it out that
sounded really generating for us
no she isn't how he shot her what good
riddance you were negotiating I heard
you you didn't have to shoot well it was
a good shot
I shot her right in the eye panicking
and shooting we almost died I shot her
so we could save David
end of story so why didn't you just
shoot you you were outnumbered they only
attacked after you pulled the trigger do
they shot Jesus Joan had to go I would
have done it too that's because you
don't mind killing people do you my god
Davey's here were your friends
Gabe that's not fair Gabe I will kill
you I will pull out your drain from your
nozzle for me when someone speaks to you
you stand up and answer them even if you
don't want to David that's enough he's
not a little boy he doesn't need that
from you
what'd he mean I am i defending him his
opinions to himself until he understands
what the hell he's talking about I'm
just I'm trying to protect you Gabe
I lost you once I won't let it happen
again okay we made it through alive
let's just be glad about that we need to
check the other entrances make sure
we're safe Gabe want to help me out javi
Gabrielle yeah go with Dave will help
him Gabe it's okay he doesn't need your
permission I'll help too
okay okay stupid game
hey cleanse with that it's fine it's not
fat it's let's just I'm all over the
place I need to focus on something
anything
magis need ya to focus I'm sorry I don't
know what's wrong with me let's just go
upstairs the further we are from these
doors a happier I'll be
I just want to get as much distance
between us and the Muertos as I can yeah
yeah okay let's go oh my god
this is a [ __ ] nightmare
it seems fine
I'm glad Mariana didn't live to see this
to see what her father's become oh my
god to see what I've done she'd be just
like that little boy scared that the
monsters are coming after her next she
would never trust us again hey come on
we're not monsters I don't know who we
are anymore
but it's not the people she knew well
come on we did what we had to do Jesus
Christ
wait don't [ __ ] out on me now what's
the big deal here we killed some people
that hole is there because oh my god I
hate when character blamed himself it's
so annoying what happened was an
accident
exactly still it happens all the time in
TV shows and having the kind of stories
one of the characters blame themselves
for something that they clearly didn't
do it's always like no way what's in
your fault and then anyone that watched
his knows that it wasn't their fault but
they're blaming themselves because
they're a good person just shut up
all right Keane let's make things right
I don't know if it's actually possible
like one of the most boring personality
traits or like a feelings or whatever
it's so I like whenever they feel guilt
I'm like just shut up just shut up
it's so boring
[Music]
sorry my little rant of the day about
guilt in movies hey how about that oh
it's you traitorous scum trip was my
best friend AVI yeah well he died
because of you he died because of you
you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] you you have no one
to blame but yourself
your actions betrayed trip exactly you
[ __ ] of how much he cared about
you I never thought it would be like
this yeah when you [ __ ] up I have to
believe that
I don't believe [ __ ] Prescott is dead
everyone but me you should be dead
instead of trip trip was a beautiful man
did you see its beard I don't have to
like it but I can't change it but you
you've got a lot of nerve showing up
here after the Bulls that you pulled
you're unbelievable absolutely
unbelievable oh [ __ ] I've got a lot of
nerve everything that happened is
because of you yeah she backed out on
the plan right I told you I didn't want
to leave you didn't listen Joan did why
did you tell Joan what we were doing I
was triaging a bad situation the doctor
is dead and before you guys [ __ ] it up
their walls worked triaging a bad
situation yeah well you made a bad
situation worse I can actually save
lives here not just ditch them up and
hope for the best
these people will die without me javi I
know she
[ __ ] us over but she's trying to help
them she's trying to make something
right that's worth forgiving right how
they talk like she's talking like she's
not there
she's got that thing now but she's got a
long way to go before I forgive her huh
you're one to talk we should try to help
not everyone here is guilty why are we
here did you see a little girl out there
she was right behind me
I'm sorry I haven't seen any little
girls strophes
she knew Rufus he was her husband until
you shot him and back
myths click one of my people Illinois
what's going on with her she'll be
alright
she's not bitten or anything she lost
her daughter out there Christ there's
nothing worse than losing a child tell
me about it
give her some privacy it's the least we
can do I want to help you okay well what
wasn't happening
[Music]
you can't even aim properly
we're dead [ __ ] meat David might as
well take out this [ __ ] while I can
she's not even aiming at me we're
shaming what about you put it down I
don't want to hurt anyone
just like you put it down for Joan stand
down look we she's Amy okay no fern this
is all because of me this is when you
tackle her explosion I killed your
daughter please forgive me it's my fault
please I am begging you I hardly have
any family left please don't take any
more away from me
yeah haha you got [ __ ] my gosh god
yeah
you're welcome Bobby I'm liking this guy
more and more hell yeah thank you my man
dazing my life she was just a scared
woman David it's done get over it hey
hell yeah
No Oh Gabe you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm sorry
that was an accident you were going to
kill her she was going for God dinner
Gabe she can't even stand up
what the hell is wrong with you it was
over the line Gabe
you're right Gabe I'm sorry I didn't
mean to do that to you you know that
why the hell you want looking at me that
way they're just they're scared David
what I'm protecting them why are you
pointing a gun at us so I'm all alone no
you can have gate find them you people
are on your own
come on he saved you I was gonna look in
his eyes before you should go after him
hey great more more talking about
feelings and we're on chapter 2 everyone
on the last episode of The Walking Dead
it's not like to call it I think that's
the title that they wanted to name it
but they didn't result me oh geez do we
just jump oh that's a long way down
yo foam bath but you'll fall all the
same
come over here or are you afraid of me
too
I know the rest of them are right even
if they are I'm not I'm terrier than you
I like him
there's no if javi
they are my wife Harvey my son they look
at me differently maybe I meant
differently I want to show you something
stand with me
that's a lot of Sam bees why the hell
are you smiling see that sewer line over
there perfect placement for a trench
that hill about a hundred paces west of
it snipers wildest dream come true
I'm a soldier hobby I see this landscape
like a painter sees a blank canvas like
how you used to see a baseball diamond
I'm a soldier
this makes sense to me
I was made for this I thrive in this
maybe it's crazy but sometimes crazy
things make sense it's an interesting a
little
I'm surprised you understand concept
soldier isn't a husband or a father a
soldier is a soldier nothing else
nothing nothing at all call yourself
whatever you want I still see you as my
brother that is kind of you to say javi
I wish
I wish I had your heart sometimes I want
to change javi I always have really all
you ever tried to do was get me to
change only because I couldn't bring
myself to do it first it's the one war I
could never win and I'm wondering why is
it because I don't know how or because
it's impossible to change who you really
are
there's a way because there's always
people you know that are just generally
violent like you just have as if they
until you find it looks pretty messy
they're better off like in the medieval
ages or some [ __ ] I guess that's the
thing then this guy just got to live
long enough to find out just like with
anything else I did what you asked you
did thanks for that so now will you'd
step back sure I found them they're a
pair you asked me to go see him careful
javi I ran into Oh Oh not Jeff oh it's
her she was still outside when we
checked on the entrances your immortals
everywhere
we got her inside just in time seriously
I've never seen so many Muertos it's
awful out there well this won't be
awkward whatsoever Ava
about earlier I guess I owe you an
explanation about what happened on the
stage with Joan and Tripp yeah what
happened anything to me your actions
said plenty I read you loud and clear
but go ahead and say whatever you want
hey don't get mad at me it was a total
no-win scenario I actually don't know
why she's pissed at me just be glad the
situation was what it was
do you and that she didn't make me pick
between you and your brother there's so
many they're pouring in
you don't know the half of it the herd
has taken over Richmond the streets are
filled with walkers with that hole in
the wall this city is [ __ ] we're not
safe here
no one is what Jesus Christ what the
[ __ ] can you go to an island or
something like that I don't want to die
up here
none of us do Gabe take out each and
every one of them the ad seemed like a
dumb idea boss Gabe likes your plan I
don't like to fight anymore what if we
use one of those you just I don't know
run them where those over that's over by
the motor pool at the water tower we
could use the highway overpass to get to
the water tower come on let's jump if
Gabe dives in this episode I'm gonna be
so happy I'll I'll forgive everything
bad that this season has been come on
it's an easy jump oh that's not gonna
break it'd be fun if we saw someone
really really fat just like one
character just been living off the
apocalypse keep your eyes open
stay aware of your surroundings all of
you let's move out like one guy found
like a storage unit with a bunch of food
or some [ __ ] just living the life she
hooked you why do you think she hugged
you what do you think just wondering
you really want to know then ask her she
won't even make eye contact with me
I'm liking this episode more now is that
guy wearing a fanny pack that's all oh
it wasn't a zombie appear or else the
exact same thing will happen to us stay
sharp and do not fire your guns
someone's gonna trip and they're all
gonna almost that guy was all alone
we're not yeah someone's definitely
gonna trip I was like oh that's awesome
a zombie with a fanny pack cuz all the
zombies look the same they never have a
personality like they all have generic
clothing usually route these walkers you
got fuck-boy
good to go let's move it'd be cool to
see like a zombie with like a blazer or
some shadow I don't know I don't know I
guess no one found by the way you okay
bud
he's fine how was that old dad used to
asked me what I wanted to be when I was
a man
and I'd wanted him
but now and ways like that I put a year
that he was such a great guy would
always make him smile David may not be
perfect but he's not the worst role
model in the world maybe hey teleporting
zombies everyone not cheese it must hurt
to hold a crowbar and they hit a really
hard object you know that was really
[ __ ] your head no wonder that all the
time don't be a man who relies on other
people to solve your problems because
then you're not a man at all
I used to kind of greedy thing not
anymore though javi I can only hope I
grow up to be like you so here's hoping
oh thanks buddy that means a lot I'm
sorry I never really said it before I
should have I don't make me like you
Gabe who Oh Camilla you took such good
care of me now we need to take care of
dad he's the one that needs our help
then go to don't go to him now Clem got
it go away from Clem please you're gonna
have to go around the side there's
barely any room
how to [ __ ] roads just collapse like
that like what happened it sounds like
there's bombs and [ __ ] she's gonna go
rogue on us isn't she
oh I got to just walk across hey
everyone I'm playing a video game I'm
pressing W holding down W it's almost
like if you do it yourself you can do a
[ __ ]
[Music]
that's pretty good you could just climb
over the carpet no how did no one see
that she died a hero sacrificed herself
to save me she was a fighter and take
[ __ ] from anybody
it was lucky to have her we all were
I would have died a long time ago
without her thank you Ava
oh no not a vine Jesus Christ I look at
an escape plan we have to get across
I'm a God Gabe I know Gabe doesn't see
it but David really is trying to look
out for him
he's not doing the best job but no one
gives you a rulebook to raise a kid and
they sure as [ __ ] don't she's just one
thing I don't get though did David
really think he was helping AJ by
letting him go why did he stop guarding
him he was afraid holding a baby in his
arms probably scared him ten times more
than any work though I don't understand
after you put in all that work so much
of your heart AJ was a brat he lived
with me after we kicked you out Club oh
[ __ ] I had already raised two kids
thought to be a piece of cake now with
that tyrant is that why you gave him
away
we had a bad winter destroyed every [ __ ]
we had
I couldn't leave Richmond and AJ
couldn't stay in Richmond
I gave AJ to lingard and told him to do
whatever he had to to save his life
I miss that bruh
never hassling guard about it again
though I've wanted to
I'll bet the little brat misses you too
both of you
well probably doesn't he Clint remember
claim remember far as I knew had already
lost two children wasn't any easier with
number three
it's never easy I'm gonna keep you alive
keep all of us alive and hope that
that's enough enough for atonement he
was a breath huh that goofy little brat
you were trying to take care of him
sometimes that's not so easy
reminds me of someone who did the same
thing for me Oh
who did the right thing
I'm surprised Kenny didn't show in this
season like I know he was in a flashback
or something like that but still like
couldn't may have brought him back I
know that for some people he died so
it's complicated or whatever but we
barely see anything of Clementine in
this she's such a small part of it she's
literally just a side character if any
if even I mean
what are they gonna do with a propeller
swing across
oh she that seems like a terrible idea
you're not thinking it's that or go back
we should go lightest to heaviest that
way it won't break on the first swing
I'll go first climb ten yeah cuz your
lightweight [ __ ] get a long run-up but
not too long if you take too many quick
steps you'll propel yourself upward
instead of out same with your jump just
run off the end
don't leave anything try not to he's got
this shut the [ __ ] up he's giving you
super useful advice that's like good
advice why not why not why not
I hope you die game I hope you know that
dime dime dime dime dime that ah thank
you how are you gonna get it back now
come on out surprisingly easy return
Gabe you have the chance to like grab
her grab her there God is such a [ __ ]
just don't die you've got this I've seen
you do things that are way scarier okay
I can do it man I'm still sick like I
feel it in my stomach
all right David you're up move a little
brother you should go first well you're
definitely lighter maybe I am younger I
really enjoyed this part so much more
than all the [ __ ] talking and all the
[ __ ] because you have a sense of
something might happen at least you know
there's a sense of something could go
bad very soon and it makes it so much
more interesting to be playing this
rather than well what do you feel I feel
guilty about this thing oh hey baby how
you doing oh [ __ ]
all right I gotta just climb up here
just grab the zombie oh nice
pretty sure that was physically
impossible but hey hey buddy how you
doing
don't mind me thank you hey you didn't
grab the hand awkward are you okay I'm
fine
[ __ ] helicopters just like planned
good work everyone just like we
rehearsed I don't know I think we can do
better head back over let's try that
again
enough come on no fun mode almost there
all right and that concludes episode
I mean chapter three of episode five
what's gonna happen who's gonna live
who's gonna die
tractor hurt it's been gonna lend from a
safe distance we need to get down there
we're not getting anywhere without one
of those vehicles it's not like we can
just ask all those walkers to move out
of the way how about we make some noise
and distract em we could use that
generator that's a great idea game
when'd you get so smart Gabe you're such
a [ __ ] idiot Gabe you really aren't
the same kid I remember I'm impressed
hey don't give him too big of a head you
still got some learning to do don't
listen to him Gabe you're doing just
fine
we still gotta get to the generator
somehow Gabe you're [ __ ] idiot I don't
want an open and cover yourself with its
guts then you can see right through them
lights all right what the [ __ ] claim oh
that's a great idea
gross idea but great I could have saved
my water bottle
so who's gonna do it you know you do
kind of owe me one
you let Conrad use me as trade that
wasn't very polite if it makes us even
look it smells really bad like way worse
than you think that's fine I'm fine all
right so here we go
top of the morning to you laddies you'll
do
we're gonna do the old smearing yourself
with [ __ ] trick the good old good old
classic
I really like the Sharkey you could do
this up here okay that could have been
more go so they definitely couldn't made
that more gross what the [ __ ]
look he's fine it's not even gonna do
some comic old zombie noises yeah that's
my zombie yeah actually that's just what
I want might said to give me food hey by
the morning to it that's my zombie hey
you a zombie yeah alrighty day [ __ ] ooh
I'm so scared I wonder what's gonna
happen is that Porter pack
hey you teleported he teleported I told
you teleporting zombies but the [ __ ]
would you saw that right you see there
is again there is again what the [ __ ] I
don't [ __ ] touch me me what oh uh huh
[Applause]
what what the actual [ __ ] happened there
[Music]
that was so [ __ ] glitched okay
so I got actually slalom my bad okay
well we were literally they're so great
hey Sam Nisha monster anyone more else
want a teleport Oh God look at that
guy's face oh don't touch me what the
[ __ ]
ridiculous he's got no muscle on his
bone and you literally just made out
with you like a vampire
this part is ridiculous it's not my
fault it's the game's fault you don't
understand okay I'm here it's a lot
easier if you just go for it
that shouldn't attract any zombies
speakers must be so useful here like if
you get a couple batteries and a
portable speaker like barely now that
we're here let's find something we can
take out all them work those with or
just accept a guy if you can just get a
jacksepticeye and throw him something
that would distract all the zombies as
well we need is the right vehicle well
that that one looks all right not gonna
do the job man yes it is what are you
doing the right thing I'm leaving we're
all leaving what and going where you saw
it yourself we're surrounded by the hurt
I'm taking my family out of here you
helped oh lewb safe Clem you're coming
too let's go everyone
we can't wait around this is [ __ ]
David absolutely not
everyone in Richmond will die without us
they don't matter javi don't you get
that this all started the day we knocked
on Richmond's door we brought this on
these people all of us we can't abandon
them not after what we've done
we're going home Kate back to the last
place we were a family we're starting
over
we're all together again finally it's
still actually don't know what to do
here all of us a new day a new life what
about here man make Richmond our new
home Richmond is gone
javi I'm not gonna let the people I
loved died trying to save a dead dream
I'll go with you dad good babe he's my
father Clem I'm sorry but you really
wouldn't understand think this over
buddy
Gabe is this what you really want I know
it's scary but I have to you don't have
to be afraid game I won't let what
happen to money on a happen to you oh my
word I will protect you the right way
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] David she was
lucky to have us
at least we were actually around a race
javi just stop he wouldn't stand for
that Loki burn huh this is what I want I
I understand Gabe I'm so sad Gabe no
please don't go yeah I won't be able to
live with myself if I don't try to help
the people in Richmond you won't be able
to live at all if you do that Richmond
is compromised doesn't matter if there
were five of us trying to save it or
five hundred we'd all die I know a
losing battle when I see one
we're moving out everybody get in that's
an order Oh [ __ ] dare you what will
it take David what will it take to show
you that you do not get to do that we
are not your soldiers run away home be a
deserter I am done with you
let's go the ring throw the ring at him
why do you think he would go with you Oh
is she gonna oh oh that's cringe dude
tell him what the [ __ ] is this papi I
love her man
we're in love oh yeah you actually you
should have picked up on it
the night you weren't there blood is
worthless to you just like he was to you
just like I am to you well it's time for
you to finally learn what blood really
means
what do you have to say for yourself
brother David stop it
I love you
oh [ __ ] no you don't get to say that
Jesus Christ stop
oh my god
how [ __ ] dare is enough stop it David
stop
I love you no stop saying that
oh oh oh hell yeah
[Music]
he looked up
well what is happening without thumbing
the back whoa
now what I feel like that could have
been emotional but it was just a little
too cheesy for my taste man I don't know
it's same bike
what the hell is he doing
Ava took him we can't wait any longer we
have to go help Richmond well he didn't
take him he wanted to go okay beep
wanted to go he did we all heard it
you're you're right
oh [ __ ] Clem oh [ __ ] Glenn Richmond
someone has to let's split up hobby I'll
go after Gabe on that motorcycle if you
don't oh hell yeah Clemence a motorcycle
you sure you'll be okay without me I can
take care of myself
we're out of time Bobby I'm sorry I've
been here before
more than once it's not gonna end well
for everyone how does she know she has
the keys
I go a little I know that I can't let
Kate go by herself
it's too dangerous I wasn't easy choice
the city okay then I'll go after Gabe
it's a smart idea
be careful out there quick you two don't
die for if you--if clam dies for Gabe
I'm done with life if we're gonna drive
into the herd we're gonna need these
hey conveniently placed ak-47s
that was Sanders Chapter three
okay [ __ ] I'm so out of it Jesus where
is this gonna go how is it gonna end
make us that's a horse
that's a badass side can you help us get
the gate open almost didn't recognize
you Jesus
it's Jesus I headed right back had to
make sure you folks were safe I think
I'm getting the hang of this
we'll keep them working throw some wine
just get me to the gate so I can open it
up hell yeah hell yeah we're gonna go in
the good ol q and a t huh I mean II
oh yeah nice nice papi the basket right
yeah Buskett
he has a [ __ ] sword
dude how are you so slow I'll have it
open in a second
they couldn't just have an open gate
button
well what you see here you want to do
you want to click the flop ah I get it
hey bingo
let's get inside regular water's
together if we get up in one group we
can lead them right out let's lead those
zombies out of mud or we could do it in
one follow me zombies [ __ ] is this
ah [ __ ] that's a lot of zombies me full
steam ahead
that just seems like a waste of ammo
like not unless they're close I would
shoot them
they'll shoot these guys
[ __ ] this
see no I'm not I'm not gonna invoice
them oh and then you die you die if that
happens oh great I thought maybe I could
observe perserve amma but I don't know
okay it's that kind of like that kind of
great all right
sorry game I didn't play exactly how you
wanted it
hey she learned what it was called how
about that
[ __ ] I'm empty
let's plug the breakdance
hey I get to drive everyone talk but I
monitor your lattice tippity tappity
there you go there you go you're welcome
new diet the super super school
that's not bad man excuse me zombies
just gonna put this car down right here
just kidding me
there's crossed
how can the bulldozer carry that
well that did a trick
that's it let's get out of here that was
it that was [ __ ] it hell yeah it's
Jesus everyone welcome back I appreciate
his man band - what well not to this
it's just a little surprising
that's all I'm just glad you didn't give
up on us
real glad I gave you my word javi look
it's Clem [ __ ] sake it's Gabe dying no
no he's just banged up
what happened click their car got
overrun with walkers and crashed I was
barely able to save Gabe what about
David David's dead yeah I'm just glad
you found cave in time
are you serious I'm sorry
no no David that was that we didn't even
get to see him die look like Rita turned
and that Gabe had to stop him
Oh God
Gabe
it's horrible
hobbie my my dad should have been you
gay buddy he's he's gone it should have
been you wanted me to tell you just care
of each other
Oh
[Music]
goddamnit where did you find them in
little ways outside of town not too far
can you take Gabe somewhere safe can you
not touch Clementine come on
where are we going
over here again it's this way
a lot of dead people in there boy
good plan there Dave good plan totally
worked out for you didn't it I guess if
you chose something else if you went
after him you would have been heap
different but I can't imagine gabe's
come a long way he's really grown did he
really need to learn this lesson though
he talked about this every day what to
do when he died
he was convinced it would happen in the
field every day as common as talking
about the weather not surprising he was
a soldier I used to hate talking about
it but it seemed to soothe him he'd talk
about his military funeral the way that
other people talked about retirement
plans he had only changed the subject if
I promised I'd bury these he didn't care
about burying his body as far as he was
concerned this was him help me dig it
doesn't have to be much
we should probably say something that's
what you do usually when you see pas you
tell them I said hi
and then I'm sorry for not paying you
back they're 10 bucks huh huh huh say
something
maybe
she should be alone with Oh in front of
the grave hell yeah
that's not we
oh she did it she left the ring hell
yeah and that's chapter for everyone we
got the final chapter coming up we're
back in Richmond it's the real Jesus
Oh
Oh see singing yeah it was his own fault
if you regret helping me if you're
feeling any guilt bury it I mean it
don't let it eat you up inside
we need to end Vaughn exactly cuz I
don't feel guilty warden that's not a
feeling I feel and no I'm not a
psychopath
we will I swear I swear guilty is for
[ __ ] guilty I feel bad
usually the quiet scares me what about
now there's a little teleported zombies
that every way the herd could come back
what do you say so positively the herd
could come back everybody still here
that I feel more calm here than and I
ever did in an old van on streets with
no streetlights we're in this hobby why
did he put those earned feeling calm in
the quiet planks on the glass that
that's so poorly placed start a family
you and me a fresh start
what do you say well if that means we're
gonna be good for us you're on let's
start a family you don't think it's
selfish it's not the safest world
outside of Richmond we're inside it
truth be told
life goes on long as I got you I'm not
too worried about it
so cheesy we'll be up there before we
know it
better do something worthwhile in the
meantime should name the kid orange or
banana or grapes or Lee
oh he teleported again have you see that
yes indeed [ __ ] my warranty rating
looks like that's been done glad we got
it settled got a move on I like you
Jesus
I gotta admit man you're [ __ ] badass
you're a real charmer you know that
through and through I meant to tell you
that a armor you got is great Oh hmm
well um thanks mr. John what the [ __ ] I
was worried about you javi the [ __ ] was
that you are inside you helped save
these people though that goes a long way
for me second chances are in short
supply these days that's what this place
can be if you let it
trust me though life within walls is a
hell of a lot different than life on the
road don't take shortcuts like John you
got to do the right thing
always good days and especially bad
absolutely the right thing no matter
what good to hear
I read people pretty well no gift in
mind you're capable guy hobby change is
in the air here you can lead that change
and I think you should for the better
god knows this not and could use it you
know what I'm gonna step up leave this
place in the right direction then as far
as I'm concerned Richmond is in much
better hands and it was hey Jesus
can I go with you yes Gabe yeah hey
whatever your name is you know not
letting me get killed and for coming
back to help us yeah thanks for that man
pay it forward
be vigilant trouble never stays too far
away
so you're out of here too huh yeah it's
time I have to find AJ javi I've waited
so long but could you do me one last
favor before I leave what what do you
want anything for you climbing my Clem
my sea girl sea dog climbing clue
climatic limited clickety clack at a
Clementine I used to do this for my
niece Oh I never seen it without the Hat
what are you it's so weird
I'm really gonna miss Gabe why he's
super annoying sometimes but all the
time doesn't used to having him around
at least to have someone to talk to even
if he is a total dork not that he said
anything to me in particular but do you
know the guys got a mondo crush on you
right
he does not oh my gosh you have a crush
on him too I do not well you both have
my blessing No what stabbed you with
those scissors how did this happen
I have to CAJ javi I have to see that
he's okay do you think he remembers me
at least a little maybe
who could forget you climb no one who
knew you I guarantee it
yeah maybe
everyone told us he was better off after
everything that's happened I'm starting
to think they're right
I don't know if I was a good mom or not
I can't stop thinking about it
I really wish I could did you love him
with all of my heart but of course you
were
oh that's sweet
[Music]
Gabe told me you used to play baseball I
did I loved it
he told me you [ __ ] it all up too
yep sure did well you survived I have to
but you loved it how do you survive that
how that's what's good about a broken
heart when you're looking at it all
broken and shattered on the floor and
you figure out the pieces you need
versus the ones you liked if you're
ready to move on that is if
where's this gonna happen
American Funds how's it look
oh so cute hey you know what I'll grab
your hat
what come on
remember this team you'd that ever teach
you about baseball no not really
no you come back I'll tell you all about
it
it's a deal it's a [ __ ] team by the way
I bring AJ back with me will you teach
him to you bet he belongs with you
Clementine
bring him back
it seemed like that was the plan anyway
but you know who cares what I think I'm
just a mayor I'll put a pad
oh I like your jacket badass
like sending your kid off to college
there she goes they grow up so fast and
then the best part is Gabe never got to
tap the head
what a beautiful landing hey that was
episode five everybody the season finale
alright so that was a cool scene I like
that half of the people okay most of the
people fought him okay and okay it's
very similar choices it's interesting
ooh
oh yeah there's always something after
the credits aren't they claim is a
[ __ ] bad-ass Jesus Christ man and how
is this gonna end cuz I remember it
season season one had like a nothing
really happening it'd be cool if
something actually happens now
clem you don't even have a backpack like
where do you keep all that ammo that was
a okay great
clementines story will continue well
that's what it should have been from the
beginning I'm sorry this really felt
like a prequel to season three they
didn't feel like its own thing at all it
didn't make any sense to me why they
focus on this story it makes sense to
building up but like it felt like the
Michonne DLC it felt very far off it
would have been cool if this was like a
DLC that kind of built on on the walk in
the next season but in the men not my
season
okay I I thought this one felt kind of
short compared to season one and season
two because they were so great and they
were by any means it wasn't bad I
enjoyed this last episode it wasn't it
wasn't bad but I expected a lot more I
think a lot of the happenings and
characters were pretty insignificant and
they sort of lost their charm didn't
they
I maybe the company grew too big for
their own good
and they'd yeah I don't know what but
like I really hope they bounce back with
that the next one with Clementine
I think clementines story is so much
more interesting and it builds on the
other seasons but you don't need a cease
whole season to build on characters like
I remember in season one just when Ben
died it [ __ ] made me sad and I hated
Ben here it's like someone dies and you
don't really care and the outcome it's
pretty much the same and I don't know
I've talked about this a lot but I still
think they can to make a really really
good game and I'm still I'm still a fan
of them but I it's just there's a bit of
a shame you know what else can you say
but nevertheless I had fun playing it I
hope you guys had fun watching it as
well leave a like if you enjoyed
watching I really appreciate it I'll see
you in the next one
and yeah let me know what you think as
well and it's always sister fist